Even in the midst of this remake and reboot-friendly
era, a lot of horror movies are just waiting
to be remade — and they could be genuinely
spectacular.
Keep your mind open and your grumblings to
a minimum, because here's a look at some horror
movies that legitimately deserve a remake.
Ever since its release in 1997, this Paul
W.S. Anderson space chiller has divided audiences
over whether it's a good time or one hell
of a terrible movie.
One thing everyone can agree on is that the
film, in which a space crew investigates an
abandoned ship only to discover it may be
a gateway to hell, is a product of its time
which hasn't exactly aged well.
In its defense, it also suffered a troubled
production history that heavily impacted the
final cut.
As fans of the film will tell you, this visceral
sci-fi-horror outing was given a preposterously
tight post-production deadline on top of studio
demands for excessive edits.
Apparently, this deeply affected the pacing
and visual effects of the theatrical cut,
and it also meant some of the film's scariest
and goriest set pieces were scrapped.
The film's notorious lost footage was unwisely
packaged off to a Transylvanian salt mine
and the resulting damage was apparently irrevocable.
In 2019, it was reported that Adam Wingard
is developing a TV adaptation of Event Horizon,
which could be great, as long as it delivers
all the vital unseen moments and plot development
that were sadly scrapped from the original.
Event Horizon deserves a remake that can finally
fulfill the gnarly, nasty vision that neither
Anderson nor the movie's audience ever got
to see.
"What happened to your eyes?"
"Where we're going, we won't need eyes to
see."
This stylish 1983 horror movie from director
Tony Scott has it all — and still makes
for a great, if quaint, viewing experience.
The Hunger uses '80s goth and New Wave culture
as its backdrop to explore a story that revolves
around addiction, sexual politics, and the
anguish of aging.
The Hunger follows a vampire named Miriam
who takes lovers that she turns into vampires.
But there's a catch: While she lives forever,
never aging, her vampiric lovers grow old
and frail while forced to subsist on human
blood.
In 2009, Warner Bros. were reportedly working
on a remake of The Hunger, though clearly
that idea seems to have been abandoned fairly
early in development.
While fans of the original underground hit
revealed they weren't happy at the prospect
of a remake, it certainly deserves one.
It's worth noting that the original ending
of The Hunger was changed at the studio's
request to leave the film open for sequels
— something cast member Susan Sarandon has
said she regrets.
On the DVD commentary, she said:
"The powers that be rewrote the ending and
decided that I wouldn't die.
Nobody knew what was going on, and I thought
that was a shame."
The ambiguous ending of The Hunger is certainly
something that could be fixed with a remake.
A 3D remake of the 1987 cult classic The Gate
was in pre-production in 2009, but sadly died
in development.
Director Tibor Takács, who helmed the original,
told Birth.Movies.Death in 2012:
"We were on board and involved in the remake
for a while and then we had a difference of
opinion and we parted ways.
I don’t even know if they shot it or not!
I can’t get a straight story."
Alex Winter of Bill & Ted fame was also on
board to direct the remake, which he planned
to use as a launchpad for an entire PG-13
horror franchise, but it unfortunately never
got off the ground.
A more modern remake of The Gate could be
perfect for reflecting youthful fears of being
powerless in the face of a world that seems
out of control.
“The old gods, the rightful masters, are
jealous, watching mankind with a hatred as
boundless as the stars."
An American remake of Battle Royale has been
at various levels of development since the
original Japanese release became a cult hit,
though various obstacles have prevented it
from coming to fruition.
Telling the story of a class of schoolchildren
in a totalitarian society who are forced to
fight to the death until a lone survivor emerges,
the film's themes remain painfully relevant
in modern America.
Sadly, that relevance has hit a little too
close to home, with one attempt at a remake
paused following the Virginia Tech Massacre.
That same remake was officially dropped in
2012 out of fears that it would look like
a rip-off of The Hunger Games, even though
Battle Royale was written years before the
first Hunger Games book.
Still, the potential to develop Battle Royale
for the next generation still exists.
Given the current sensitivity over mass violence,
especially when it concerns children, it's
likely to be met with controversy, but maybe
that's exactly the reason why this film deserves
to be remade.
Centered around a pack of practical-joke loving
college students who end up being picked off
by a mysterious killer with a cruel sense
of humor, April Fool's Day is quite possibly
one of the dumbest, and most fun, slasher
movies of its time.
Leading the ill-fated group of teens is an
unconventional Final Girl named Muffy St.
John, an eccentric, wealthy teenager with
plenty of mansion space to share with her
ill-fated coeds.
April Fool's Day is packed full of ridiculous
plot twists and red herrings, as well as obnoxious
rich kids getting slaughtered in ridiculous
ways.
In short, it's everything you could want from
the genre.
This film actually did receive a remake in
2008, but the direct-to-video film wasn't
able to tap into the core comedic appeal of
the original.
With the rise of internet pranksters turned
viral stars like YouTube celebrities, we're
in what can only be described as a prankster
renaissance.
A newly modern remake may not retain the same
cheesy charm as the original, but it could
still be timely and huge amounts of fun — especially
if it means seeing YouTube pranksters getting
their hilariously hideous comeuppance.
The horror genre is long overdue for the arrival
of a smart, grown-up slasher franchise.
While most horror fans would likely prefer
an original take on what that would look like,
there's something intriguing about the prospect
of remaking horror satire The Slumber Party
Massacre for modern audiences.
The subversive cult classic from director
Amy Holden Jones and writer Rita Mae Brown
was dismissed as little more than a derivative
slasher-by-numbers when it was released
in 1982.
"Dog's in the trash again."
“So go take care of it."
"What do you think I am, stupid? I'm not going out there alone in the dark."
Since then, the film has since been hailed
for skewering the overt misogyny of the slasher
genre in its revolt against genre tropes.
Jones has expressed some regrets about having
to include gratuitous nudity in the film's
early shower scene, which she has said was
unavoidable.
Producer Roger Corman insisted on the scene's
inclusion because, according to Jones:
"Nudity was more important to [Roger Corman]
than sex and you know he has to sell the thing"
It's a horror trope that's been gradually
forced out of the genre, and even subverted
in modern entries like Midsommar.
Shout!
Factory acquired Corman's library in 2018
and have reportedly expressed interest in
a potential remake.
There are currently plenty of incredible female
horror directors who could take a confident
swing at it, so here's hoping that they get
the chance to make their bloody mark.
The Return of the Living Dead continues to
be one of the most fun horror movies ever
made, and one which provides a neat time capsule
in celebrating some of the subversive youth
culture of the '80s.
The Return of the Living Dead is pure punk
rock, right down to the set dressing and outfits
worn by the cast.
That punk spirit includes authentic depictions
of punk culture, but it also has an aggressively
irreverent anti-establishment stance, which
is emphatically anti-military.
It's rare to find similarly authentic depictions
of young, rebellious subcultures in modern
horror, or anywhere in contemporary cinema,
for that matter.
The fact that there's no modern-day remake
of The Return of the Living Dead could be
considered a real wasted opportunity when
youth subcultures are arguably the most visible
and politically active they have been in decades.
There's definitely an argument to be made
the last decade has given us enough zombie
films and TV shows to last a lifetime and
beyond.
Still, there's still something intriguing
about discovering a fresh zombie narrative
which has a slightly different story to tell.
A modern-day remake of Sugar Hill could be
the one that could brings fresh life to the
overdone genre.
As much a revenge movie as it is a zombie
flick, this underrated 1974 blaxploitation
horror film follows a woman who summons an
army of zombies to seek revenge against the
mobsters who killed her boyfriend.
With an empowered African-American woman leading
the story, Sugar Hill takes on feminist issues
alongside some sharp commentary regarding
racism and class.
Most importantly, it does all of this while
still being extremely entertaining.
With the current renaissance of black horror
pushing African-American narratives and concerns
to the forefront of a genre that hasn't always
been so historically inclusive, Sugar Hill
could make for an incredible mainstream Hollywood
remake that's well deserved.
Anyone who holds a place for this '80s classic
in their hearts will be well aware of the
fact that The Monster Squad, in which a group
of witty, talkative kids take on some classic
monsters in their hometown, is arguably one
of the biggest influences on the current pop
culture trend of kids-vs.-monsters content.
From Stranger Things to the Child's Play reboot
and Scary Stories to Tell in the Dark and
the new It, you can't go far without bumping
into stories about children fighting monsters.
In recent years, Monster Squad filmmakers
Fred Dekker and Shane Black even had to let
go of their idea for a 30 years later sequel
to the original because everyone's already
doing exactly that.
As Dekker put it:
"I thought, well, let's make this movie for
the people who fell in love when they were
kids and say, 'Where is the squad as adults?'
And Shane said to me, 'Well that's it.'
I said, 'Yeah, it's a great idea.'
And he goes, “No, that's Stephen King's
‘It.’ the first part of the book and the
first movie is them as kids fighting monsters
and the second movie is them as adults fighting
monsters.”
But it's the ubiquity of these tropes which
could actually make for a great remake of
The Monster Squad, particularly if it added
a fresh, modern take while parodying current
trends.
Though nothing could beat the original, there's
definitely potential in a story that sees
a bunch of desensitized kids rolling their
eyes at the threat of a bunch of old-school
classic monsters.
Maybe a Monster Squad remake could finally
bring that Blumhouse shared universe to fruition,
with a gang of kids sneeringly taking on the
horror studio's most notorious foes.
The fact that we haven't gotten a remake already
is completely:
"Bogus."
Starring Vincent Prince as a sour old thespian
who enacts ghastly acts of vengeance against
his worst critics, this British tongue-in-cheek
horror outing is an underrated classic.
The film leans confidently into camp sensibilities
and takes great glee in some of the most preposterous,
and elaborate, murder scenes in horror comedy
history.
The inspirations for each are taken from classic
deaths of various Shakespeare plays, which
played perfectly to early '70s British audiences
when the film was released.
Although Theater of Blood continues to enjoy
a strong cult following, it's difficult to
imagine young audiences connecting with it
in quite the same way.
However, in focusing on how critics can wield
their power, the underlying themes of Theater
of Blood remain familiar.
After all, we live in a time when anyone can
take to social media to be as careless and
cruel as they like about art and the people
who make it.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.